>> I say the answer to this question is definitely
yes. Role models are a very integral part
for what will make the Middle East in the
near future. There are some role models in
particular who really serve as a great example
for the youth in the Middle East today. Some
of these include [inaudible] seeking Abdullah
whose balanced moderation with his taking
of Western ideals and combining it with a
cultural aspects of the Middle East and make
for a great output in Jordan. And also other
examples include [inaudible] the Foreign Minister
of Iraq and [inaudible] who also serve as
great role models in that region. It really
doesn't come down to the fact that 70% of
the Middle East is now made up of the youth
and therefore what serves as an example to
them is an integral part to what will make
the Middle East as a whole in the near future.